ich jetzt gerade ausfahre geht's aber
trotzdem hier ich hüpfe erstmal was
hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer Runde
Disney Infinity das ganze ist ein mehr
oder weniger neues Spiel von Disney und
zwar ist das Ganze kostenlos man kann
sich dann irgendwie mit echten Geld
Charaktere kaufen wie beispielsweise die
Avengers habe ich hier am Start ich habe
hier den Iron Man und sitz gerade auf
dem richtig schniaken Motorrad diese
scheiß Passanten gehen hier einfach
Alter lasst mich immer bitte könnt ihr
vielleicht diese e was ist den mit
dieser Oma los juck mich nicht ich gegen
ja ja Sache ist ich habe mir gedacht
dass oder redet einer mit mir ich soll
irgendwie
bitte das
ist Alter was geht guckt euch das mal an
[Musik]
alter oh junge ich habe das Spiel vorhin
schon bisschen angezockt ich bin hier
Iron Man und musste vorhin so ein paar
eiskönige Alter das
Lenken das lenkt mit dem Motorrad kann
ich noch nicht so gut ich habe vorhin
schon ein bisschen angezockt in der
Arena von diesem in dem stark Tower hier
hier mit dem Iron Man um herauszufinden
wie das Ganze überhaup funktioniert und
bin jetzt hier in der Open World also
das ist so ein bisschen wie GTA nur
nicht so krass mit den ganzen Waffen
aber Alter gibt euch das mal diese
ganzen Autos ich muss nur einmal
gegenfahren ist irgendein
coin du hast eine mixmünze gefunden sie
damit okay chillig wo sind Passanten wo
sind Passanten da ist jemand treff ich
den Treff das ist eine Parkuhr ich voll
Idiot ich bin Lua ich verwechsel
Passanten mit
Parkuhren ja ja stark Tower ich bin
sofort da pass auch richtig cool ist
wenn man so ein Passanten einfach
hochhebt und dann irgendwie auf so ein
Auto draufft das juckt in einfach nicht
der fliegt da drauf denkt sich so Yolo
zack ich lauf einfach weiter die hier
sieht so ein bisschen aus wie wie
krancrafter komm nehmen mal guck mal die
spricht sogar auch so neh mal
krancrafter und grünes Auto ist ja sein
Lieblingsfarbe juck nicht kann ich
eigentlich Autos lol ich kann Autos
hochheben m bestimt wen ich mein Auto
auf ein Motorrad auf mein Motorrad drauf
werfe geht bestimmt das Auto auch kaputt
oder Alter wahrscheinlich ich gehe
erstmal zum stark Tower damit ich hier
noch ein bisschen W m das ist wie
Motorradfahren mit einem
leistungsfähigen hochmodernen Turbomotor
ja ich habe ein schieldmotorrad in der
toybox Alter let s
tschüss stell euch mal vor kommt einer
echt zu mir hin hey con oh meine facecam
ist verschwommen hey Cony können wir ein
Foto machen ja klar und dann nehme ich
einfach weg wie geil W das denn kann ich
diesen Typen hier irgendwie hochheben ne
kann ich nicht kann ich den Boxen oh lol
geh sterben Alter du kack
Blödmann junge juck die nicht was ist
wenn ich dein Auto nehme ja okay das
Auto juckt auch nicht so ich gucke mal
ob ich jetzt hier irgendwie ein cooles
das ist nur der Fähigkeitenbaum ich
brauche irgendwie mein ich brauche mal
eine Karre ah hier nee hä
oh lol was geht Alter also ich muss echt
sagen D ist das Chrysler Building mir
gefällt das da ist das Empire State
Building nee da ist das Empire
statebilding das das Chrysler Building
ich voll Idiot ich war noch nie in New
York eigentlich eine Stadt die mich
nicht so reizt muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen also mal eben so ein bisschen of
topic New York reizt mich nicht so mich
reizt eher so Kanada etwas so in die
Richtung Natur Alter aber was geht denn
das sieht echt alles mega nice aus muss
ich eigentlich mal sagen also die Grafik
ist zwar so ein bisschen com commäig
gehalten und ich habe die Grafik jetzt
auch nicht auf voll Power stehen weil
ihr wisst ich habe nicht so PC aber mein
neuer PC kommt in 11 Tagen
wahrscheinlich aber ich weiß nicht ich
feier das
Alter Alter wie weit ich hier gucken
kann alles
zerstören so wie mit den Autos
Alter wieso ist da oben eine Reklame von
Spider-Man und nicht von mir da hinten
ist die die Freiheitsstatue wollen wir
mal einfach kann ich nicht hier
irgendwie mit einem Doppelsprung
vielleicht irgendwie ne das war genau
das was ich verme WTE ich muss echt
sagen es macht mir Spaß das Spiel ist
zwar wirklich eher also man sieht schon
es ist eigentlich nicht so für mein
Alter also für 18 19 jährige so um den
Dreh
alter das ist echt einfach was geht man
ich muss echt sagen es gefällt mir das
ist so ein bisschen schwachsinnig aber
es ist cool guckt euch diese Kacke an ah
hier kann ich mir
mein Fahrzeug herbeirufen das aber ich
habe halt nur ein Shield Motorrad aber
na ja das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal
ganz geil und jetzt habe ja gerade
erfahren dass ich eine Mission habe es
ist echt schwer zu steuern ladet euch
das mal selbst runter und sagt mir dann
wie ich das richtig oh ich habe eine
Münze guck mal hier ist das direkt dann
mache ich mal eben hier Zack und rette
eben die Welt okay was ist jetzt das ist
halt ganz easy man kann sie einfach
hinstellen und die ganze Zeit so
komische Teile Schießen mit oh da sind
mehr als nur einer dann kann ich das
natürlich nicht machen jetzt kommen
wieder hier und jetzt
ausweichen und
Kombo
mach doch die Combo jetzt da und BAM der
ist schon tot Infinity also man muss
echt sagen das Spiel hat keine richtige
Handlung es ist halt einfach nur so ein
bisschen Open World mäßig und man hat
ein paar Missionen muss ja aber nicht
machen sondern man kann auch einfach nur
hier im Park so ein bisschen Spaß haben
und irgendwelche Bänke zerschlagen oder
irgendwelche latnen oder einfach
rumfliegen oder so aber ich mache jetzt
mal eben ich geh mal zu meinem Motorrad
kann ich eigentlich irgendwie schneller
laufen oh ich habe schon wieder
abgeschossen e guck mal das blbert
richtig cool BL ab zum nächsten Ziel von
dem ich gerade weggefahren bin chillig
er kann mit Motorrad rückwärts fahren
gut ja ist halt echt so ich bin halt
wirklich einfach weggefahren obwohl mein
Ziel direkt hier ist nein Alter der kann
hüpfen er kann einfach hüpfen auf dem
Motorrad kann er doch nicht drück und
halte spacebum zu schweben was
lol was
geht Alter ich kann einfach hochfliegen
ich bin ja auch Iron Man stimmt so was
geht hier jetzt ab muss ich nicht hier
irgendwie was machen oder irgendwie so
ah ich muss benutzen und jetzt eins von
drei und jetzt habe ich irgendwo anders
ein nächstes Ziel ich habe aber keinen
Bock diese Mission zu machen ich bin
noch so jemand der GTA spielt aber nicht
die Mission macht sondern cheatet und
dann mit dem Helikopter auf dem Hochhaus
fliegt und dann Polizisten abknallt oder
irgendwie sowas mein jetziges Ziel ist
zur Freiheitsstatue chuldigung
entschuldigung ich habe ein Ziel ich
habe eine Mission bei GTA standen
hierimmer so Helikopter oder ja oh
das ist aber kacke wenn man im Wasser
tot ist das ist bisschen do ich schwebe
da jetzt einfach rüber Freunde ich
schwebe da jetzt habe ich irgend Balken
der mir sagt dass nicht mehr schwebt
kann oder so oder irgendeine Energie ich
komme der Freiheitsstatue näher das muss
man sagen e ich kann einfach während des
Schwebens auch noch schießen was geht
schieß einfach die Freiheitsstatue ab
unten ist übrigens so ein cooler blauer
Balken ihr seht schon oben ich habe so
jetzt muss ich natürlich treffen erstmal
ne das ist wie meine Landebahn jetzt
hier GU mal da links sind auch so
richtig hohe Türme ich verstehe nicht
wie diese Stadt aufgebaut ist ihr seht
oben links in dieses blaue und das wird
jetzt beispielsweise auch ein bisschen
mehr das sind so Sachen mit denen ich
mir spät meine Charaktere irgendetwas
kaufen kann oder mir Charaktere kaufen
kann glaube ich als ich es angespielt
habe war das auf jeden Fall so ich
fliege jetzt erstmal diese freiheitsstat
hoch ich weiß oh da oben ist ein
komischer Block et in
Minecraft eine bonusbox gefunden
durchsuche das playet mit
unterschiedlichen Figuren um alle zu
finden und zu öffnen okay danke Freunde
man muss schon sagen das ganze sieht
schon fett aus ne wenn ich hiermer so
rumgcke also ich weiß nicht ob ich noch
nach da hinten hin kann aber das könnten
wir rein theoretisch auch mal
ausprobieren jetzt wenn man sich das
hier so anguckt so hier überall sieht
schon fett aus ne mit der ganzen Skyline
und alles ich gucke auch immer ich habe
die Webcam jetzt woanders also die
Webcam nicht die Webcam ist immer noch
da oben von der Seite aber mein Bild ist
wo anders und warum erzähle ich e das
mein letztes Ziel für dieses Video ist
einfach auf das Empire State Building
das ist das Empire State Building ja
Luca das ist glaube ich das höchste
Gebäude in New York und bzw in wie heißt
diese Stadt die heißt auf jeden Fall
nicht Spark town sie heißt Spark Tower
also Spark Tower ist dieser Turm aber
wie heißt dieses Ding und da ist ist ein
a für Avengers wie heißt do mal die
Stadt in Avengers oder in in in Iron Man
weiß gar nicht mer da oben ist schon
wieder so eine Box wie geil oh ich
bin viel zu weit oben bleib ruhig ich
bin in der Box drin nein hol dir die Box
alles gut alles gut da ist die Box und
jetzt Flugmodus verlassen und
runterfallen oh cool bin auf Gebäude am
R du
blöde
erm wieder das Shield Motorrad hier an
Start holen ich könnt mir echt
vorstellen hier mehrmals was hochzuladen
ich hatte zwar sehr sehr viele Probleme
das ganze aufzunehmen aber ich wollte
unbedingt mal aufnehmen weil es ist
quasi GTA aber nicht krass brutal wisst
okay da vorne ist irgendwo eine Brücke
die muss ich jetzt erstmal irgendwie
finden wie ich da hochke Achtung heiß
und fertig also wenn ich ein Kritikpunkt
habe dann eindeutig die Steuerung es ist
so schwammig mit dem Motorrad zu fahren
wenn ich jetzt gerade ausfahre geht's
aber trotzdem hier ich hüpfe erstmal was
ich wollte im hüpfen lenken und dann
habe ich einfach so ein Stunt gemacht
Alter läuft bei mir
oh s das denn ich glaube die skylineer
hinten ist echt gesperrt das ist ein
bisschen doof na ja fahre ich wieder
zurück Alter ich komme nicht ich ich
fahre immer wieder gegen die Wand und
dann wieder gegen die na egal ich würde
auf jeden Fall sagen Freunde das war's
mit diesem Video ich habe mal einfach
jetzt dieses Disney Infinity so ein
bisschen angespielt bisschen
unrealistisch und die Steuerung ist
bisschen schwammig aber an sich eine
gute Idee äh quasi GTA so ein bisschen
ähm ein bisschen so Open World obwohl es
ist ja nicht unbedingt GTA ich meine es
gibt ja voll viele Open World Spiele da
muss ich ja nicht unbeding GTA als be
ranziehen aber es ist auf jeden Fall
cool ich find es witzig ich fand auch
die anfangsmission ganz geil wo man
quasi durch so ein interaktives Tutorial
die Steuerung gelernt hat ich hasse das
immer wenn man gesagt bekommt ja das ist
deine Steuerung und hier mach jetzt mal
was raus sondern es ist wirklich so ja
hier ist ein Feind drück die und die
Taste um ihn zu töten und so das ist
eigentlich ganz chillig gewesen ich
würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann
Daumen nach oben und ein Link zum Spiel
ist in der Beschreibung falls ihr
runterladen wolltest ist kostenlos von
daher könnt ihr das Ganze locker mal
anzocken und dann sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten Video wieder
tschüss